(intense music)
- Superheroes.
We can't relate to 'em.
None of us can fly.
So, Superman's like an alien
from a different planet
to us, ya know?
We've been lied to, okay?
What we need is a
superhero that makes us all
feel like we could
be superheroes.
Enter, the de-constipator.
Right there.
You hear his superpower,
it's in his name.
See, I don't care what
kinda bad guy you are.
I don't care how evil you are.
You're gonna stop whatever
wrongdoings you're doing
once the de-constipator
starts doo-dooing.
- Thank you de-constipator.
- And what superhero
is complete without an
arch nemesis?
Exactly, that's where the
blackout baron comes in.
He has the power to
sleep with anyone
as long as they're
both blackout drunk.
Luckily, the de-constipator
will stop at nothing
until he gives the
blackout baron the ultimate
booty call.
So, what's your feeling on this?
Are you thinking ya know,
Michael Bay blockbuster or maybe
Kathryn Bigelow awards sweep
'cause I'm even considering
like Netflix series.
- If I sent that
script to any director
about a superhero called
the de-constipator,
they'd use it to wipe their ass.
- Better name.
I see what you're
saying, better name.
I'm with you on that, okay?
- Call my assistant, alright?
Better yet, fuck off, alright?
Fuck off.
Good to see ya.
Anywhere, just go, hurry up.
- I think I sold that.
I think I fuckin' sold that.